with that boy he didn't get touched did
not bet everybody watching long leg off
he's too athletic he went say less check
this out
there's your World Champ Heavyweight
World Champ
who wants to argue he's not to go go
ahead I'm listening I don't know why you
were looking at me he made it look easy
too this was a good matchup for him the
guy has no grappling he went straight to
him like like butter went straight to
Mound what what just happened the
greatest of all time literally found a
guy who's never followed Grappler got
taken down within the first minute and
panicked and got choked out with a
guillotine what a waste of money but it
was some other good fights on the cards
don't dance in the booty stores
tonight in Vegas
that boy getting loose